[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés votre
rendez vous hebdomadaire pour débattre
discuter et réfléchir sur les grands
enjeux qui touchent nos vies et qui font
l'actualité
ce soir nous échangerons sur comment
l'épidémie de koffi 19 impacte les
diverses associations yvelinoise des
conséquences financières humaines ou
encore sportive des événements annulé
des représentations reporter des saisons
sportives blanche et des besoins des
deux toujours plus grand selon une
enquête menée par le mouvement
associatif du 18 mai au 15 juin
89% des associations confirmé avoir eu
des difficultés dans leurs activités de
bénévolat
plus de la moitié d'entre elles ont dû
revoir leur mode de fonctionnement
alors pendant les prochaines minutes
nous allons échanger que trois invités
issus de différents lieux d'association
en plateau avec nous franck lecarpentier
vous êtes le président des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux équipe et club de
baseball bonsoir bonsoir et ils seront
en visio avec nous françoise de saldé
l'air bonsoir ou bonjour la présidente
danny masa ce collectif de
d'associations et d'habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines et pascal rebetez
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes secrétaire
général de la fédération des yvelines du
secours populaire français
mais avant de commencer à échanger avec
vous trois je vous propose qu'on écoute
patricia blanc elle est la présidente
d'image in for margot l'association dont
le siège se trouve dans les yvelines se
bat contre les cancers pédiatriques
elle a choisi d'organiser sa course
enfants sans cancer de manière connecter
plus d'un million d'euros a été collecté
grâce à trois mille participants à
travers la france
et on vient de m'apprendre que nous
n'avons pas le magnéto donc elle nous
informer notamment dans ce ghetto qu'il
fallait innover il fallait se renouveler
françoise de salir injustement à cette
manière d'innover de se renouveler en ce
mois de septembre l'île de loisirs
aurait dû accueillir la première édition
d'un festival que vous portez c'est le
festival pulsations il est reporté à
2021 mais vous aviez tenu à organiser le
25 et le 27 septembre dernier
le club des partenaires un rendez-vous
lui aussi modifié est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer tout à fait c'est vrai
que il y a beaucoup de d'effets négatifs
de des contraintes sanitaires liés à la
cause vide
il ya aussi certains effets positifs
c'est que lorsqu on reporte des
événements comme ça a été le cas pour le
festival ça nous donne du temps donc on
va dire qu'on profite de ce temps on
essaye de positiver de cette année
supplémentaire qui nous est donnée pour
créer et notamment créé le club des
partenaires du festival pulsations le
premier rendez vous devait avoir lieu
vendredi dernier et la préfecture nous a
fortement recommandé d'annuler ce
premier rendez vous donc voilà donc
comme vous disiez précédemment il faut
sans cesse se réinventer sans cesse
rebondir
c'est vrai que c'est un peu compliqué
parce qu'on parle de bénévolat on parle
de membres associatifs etc on est sur
des dynamiques
voilà deux dates du temps et c'est quand
même un peu compliqué de rebondir 107
est-ce que ça a été un coup dur toutes
ces annulations successives tout à fait
ça a été ça a été compliqué
alors tout ça s'est fait pendant le
confinement ce qui a encore intensifié
la complexité de la chose puisque on est
tous passés en visio donc c'est vrai que
là aussi on se renouvelle un on a
découvert qu'on n'avait pas besoin
d'être présentiel il n'empêche que pour
tout ce qui concerne le lien c'est quand
même bien compliqué de faire du lien en
étant en virtuel donc ça c'est très
compliqué ensuite c'est vrai que nos
troupes de bénévoles ont été elles aussi
touchées par par l'aco l'idée ça
continue de l'être puisque les nouveaux
membres qu'on intègre sont des étudiants
et que les étudiants sont en ce moment
dans des conditions un peu difficiles
aussi dans les amphithéâtres
donc voilà on reçoit sans cesse des
messages disant qu'ils sont empêchés
pour cause de tests positifs
voilà donc tout est compliqué toute
cette dynamique est extrêmement
compliqué et il faut maintenir une
dynamique malgré tout alors cette dame
imagine fort margot on va écouter
comment il faut il joue malgré la queue
19 on n'a pas trop le choix
en fait notre course à saint-cloud
normalement fait 5 à 6000 personnes sur
site
donc on a vu très rapidement qu'on
n'allait pas pouvoir la faire
entièrement sur site
on est passé tout de suite en un mode
mixte à la fois connecté et sur site
et puis on début septembre lorsqu'on a
vu que les choses allaient conditions
sanitaires se compliquer on a passé sur
un mode entièrement connectée connectés
ça veut dire que sur place il y avait
juste en fait une équipe de tournage
avec quelques animations en les
personnes qui allaient monter sur le
podium et on a retranscrit un événement
pour des personnes qui étaient qui
courait en fait partout en france et
même à l'étranger de tous nos événements
ont été annulés
il faut savoir que à peu près 200
événements sont faits pour l'association
par des par des bénévoles des personnes
extérieures
on a aussi un deuxième événement qui
s'appelle le rallye du coeur nous ce
sont des voitures de collection ou des
voitures de sport qui se réunissent à
personne et avec normalement un enfant
avec sa famille dans les voitures donc
cette année impossible de mettre des
enfants dans les voitures
donc on a fait un parrainage entre des
pilotes et des enfants
[Musique]
on a peu été touchée dans l'association
par des par des personnes qui ont le
quotid ou alors ils l'ont eue mais pas
de manière très très grave
ça en fait un pacte et l'association en
tant que tel parce qu'on a il a fallu
qu'on se réorganise complètement le jour
au lendemain on a été en télétravail
donc voilà on a bien connu les réunions
en vision et le suivi de tout ce qu'on
fait en visite ou donc c'était comment
est-ce qu'on garde le contact entre nous
mais comment aussi on garde le contact
avec nos partenaires avec les familles
avec les hôpitaux
donc voilà ça a été comme moi qu'on
rentrait du contact à distance
on a beaucoup entendu le mot visio mais
il faut que les carpentier chez vous
c'est impossible
du côté des cougars la commune 19 a été
synonyme d'arrêt complet la saison n'a
pas repris au printemps
oui alors nous c'est vrai qu'on est un
sport un peu particulier c'est qu'en
fait nous notre saison commence au
printemps
donc en fait au début du cloisonnement
en fait la question s'est posée tout le
monde espère exxon dure qu'un mois
comme partout en france et bah force a
été de constater que dans un premier
temps on a décalé la saison à début mai
et au final elle a été purement et
simplement annulée donc nous gros effet
oui effectivement de ce côté là sur
l'aspect sportif physique pour vos
joueurs un manque d'entraînement tel un
manque de matches ça implique quoi pour
la suite alors j'ai deux catégories de
joueurs
il n'y a que la france aujourd'hui qui a
annulé son championnat j'ai une bonne
partie de mes joueurs en fait qu'ils
sont partis jouer à l'étranger en suède
en suisse un petit peu partout ailleurs
en europe on en avait aussi quelques
heures états unis ou même un au
venezuela
donc tout cela ont pu jouer donc au
niveau forme n'y a pas de souci pour eux
ils ont joué à des championnats qui
conte et niveau à peu près homologue au
nôtre pour ceux qui sont restés c'était
beaucoup beaucoup plus compliqué
effective
pascal rodier vous ce n'est pas
nécessairement des à l'une des
annulations mais des modifications en
mars vous fermer le siège départemental
vous avez même dû fermer certaines
antennes comme celui de conflans sainte
honorine
aujourd'hui vous en êtes où en fait
pendant la crise colis il ya eu
effectivement un temps de latence sur
deux structures locales et puis
finalement ça s'est débloqué après s'il
y avait beaucoup d'appréhension des
bénévoles qui souvent dans une
association comme la nôtre sont un peu
âgés et donc se sentait pas prendre de
risques inutiles on a une forte
mobilisation bénévole nouveau puisqu'on
a plus de 400 bénévoles qui se sont
proposés qui faisait pas partie de nos
effectifs et c'était plutôt des les
actifs qui se retrouvaient empêché de
travailler du coup du fait du
confinement et donc du coup c'est vrai
que le siège départemental étant
essentiellement administratifs
on a opté pour le télétravail mais on a
tout de même aussi étant une association
de solidarité du projeter des amis sur
le terrain pour accompagner les
bénévoles dans la réorganisation et tout
est donc là ce qu'on peut dire si vous
voulez c'est que nous y compris là avec
la deuxième vague
on a serré ouverts partout et on a même
des nouvelles structures qui s'ouvre du
fait qu'il ya de nouvelles personnes qui
sont proposés donc je pense qu'on peut
dire qu'on a réussi à peu prêt à
rebondir en termes de d'animation là où
c'est peut-être un petit peu plus
compliqué c'est sur la partie purement
statutaire quand il s'agit de tenir des
assemblées générales d'approbation
compter tous armés comme certaines
associations là un petit peu en ce
moment à bousculer les calendriers
d'habitude on les fait en juin et là on
n'a pas pu le faire mais sur la
mobilisation solidaire ne peut pas dire
que ça se soit ralenti puisque on aime
on a toujours été actif en en fait
pendant toute la crise voilà franck
lecarpentier je vous ai vu à quai c'est
sur les statuts puisque les associations
il ya aussi tout un domaine
administratif ça vous met dans
l'embarras
c'est évident nous comme je l'expliqué
ans commence au printemps
donc c'est à dire qu'en fait on a entamé
toute note sic de dépenses pour préparer
la saison et on s'est retrouvé au début
de saison sans aucune rentrée puisque en
fait on a trois types de rentrer chez
nous on a les subventions publiques qui
bien heureusement ont été maintenus donc
l'on remercie d'ailleurs chaleureusement
la mairie l'agglomération la région et
le ministère des sports parce que sans
eux on aurait passé la clé sous la porte
par contre en fait on avait tous nos
nouveaux textiles et la buvette qui
tourne et pops tout simplement il n'y
avait pas de match donc pour l'instant
un manque à gagner estimé à 32000 euros
donc c'est pour nous c'est énorme qui ne
sera jamais comblé j'imagine qui sera
jamais comblé après faut voir aussi
qu'on n'a pas dépensé d'argent vue qui a
pas eu la saison pour les deux équipes
en division nationale donc ça équilibre
un petit peu
en fait la perte réelle si on estime les
dépenses qu'on n'a pas fait elle est de
7000 euros
françoise des salles de l'air cet impact
financier vous le ressentez aussi
aujourd'hui vous est-ce que vous devez
vous battre pour garder vos subventions
vous avez un accord pour maintenir en
oui alors je rejoins tout à fait ce qui
a été dit sur la difficulté
administrative c'est à dire que nous
nous n'avons pu bénéficier que de la
subvention de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui nous est restée
tandis que les autres les autres
soutiens département et ile de france à
partir du moment où le l'événement n'a
pas lieu ne donne pas de subventions
dans le domaine culturel
donc nous avons tout le travail qui a
été fait pendant toute l'année puisque
les subventions c'est un travail de
dossiers d'instruction dossier qui se
fait dans l'univers en fait tout est à
refaire
donc il faut entièrement refaire toutes
les instructions de dossiers revoir tous
les partenaires c'est un gros gros
travail à refaire nous nous sommes
beaucoup en contact avec les élus dont
qui aiment des élections depuis ce qui
fait que nous avons un manque itunes
j'appelle ça une campagne presque une
campagnard offert pour à nouveau
représenter notre et vers notre
événement voilà tout ce qui peut
apporter à toute notre région et
financièrement bien sûr c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que les
artistes nous nous sommes en relation
avec les producteurs des artistes et les
artistes sont devenus beaucoup plus
frileuses qu'on comprend très bien donc
voilà et il nous demande beaucoup plus
d' avance financière que nous n'avons
pas puisque nous n'avons pas eu les
subventions
donc tout est beaucoup plus compliqué au
niveau de la construction de l'événement
justement vous parlez des artistes le
monde culturel c'est un univers qui se
sent abandonnée qui s'est senti
abandonné qu'il se soit encore est ce
que votre absence et votre association a
ce sentiment aussi qu on vous oublie
alors on fait beaucoup pour qu'on nous
oublie pas donc on n'a pas cette
sensation réellement parce qu'on essaye
d'être très présent mais c'est vrai que
c'est un gros travail de mobilisation
après on se rappelle beaucoup au
souvenir de ceux qui avaient décidé de
nous soutenir et et voilà on essaye
d'être présent auprès de ceux qui ne
nous soutiennent pas encore mais qui
auront sûrement mais les artistes eux
amateurs et professionnels se sentent en
effet complètement délaissé oui alors
sous plusieurs de plusieurs façons
exemple une pratique donc déjà ça c'est
extrêmement compliqué pour un artiste
ils n'ont plus de production donc ils
peuvent plus être programmés et son va
être très très compliqué pour tous les
actes parce qu'elle revient les deux
autres associations sont plutôt à
l'arrêt vous c'est presque inverse ce
confinement cette maladie il ya plus de
besoins j'imagine c'était plus de
bénéficiaires déjà on a été un petit peu
en surchauffe quand même au moment de la
crise dans la mesure où il ya quand même
pas mal d'associations qui n'était pas
en capacité de se mobiliser au niveau où
on aurait pu s'y attendre donc que du
coup on a eu un peu un transfert de
masse de public et puis on a eu beaucoup
de nouveaux publics qu'il a fallu aider
notamment les personnes âgées isolées
les personnes en hôtels sociaux qui se
retrouvait complètement démuni par
rapport aux aides traditionnelles et on
a eu aussi des étudiants dans le cadre
d'un partenariat qu'on a pris on a passé
avec le crous y à peu près 20% des
étudiants hébergé en crous dans l'est
dans les yvelines qui se seront
trouvaient confinées donc un petit peu
bloqué sans ressources dans leur
hébergement et donc grâce à un
partenariat n'a plus comme ça apporter
des aides alimentaires de base et
d'hygiène
donc ça a été une grosse surchauffe
d'activité comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
450 nouveaux bénévoles
à mettre en mouvement sur 25 structures
locales c'est pas une mince affaire mais
on est je pense que comme beaucoup
d'associations de solidarité de terrain
en fait
l'urgence fait que les gens quand même
réussi ça à trouver des nouveaux
ressorts des nouvelles énergies et les
gens sont quand même très inventif on a
pu mettre en place des collectes en pied
d'immeuble on a eu des entreprises aussi
qu'on était généreuse avec nous et puis
les pouvoirs publics ont bien mesuré
aussi les enjeux et donc ont quand même
un peu fait des facilités notamment pour
les équipements de protection des
bénévoles avec la tdc est là dit par la
direction départementale de la cohésion
sociale a pu être soutenu et puis on a
la chance d'être un réseau national
structure et aussi au niveau régional et
donc on a mutualisé aussi nos efforts et
nos capacités notamment au niveau de la
solidarité matérielle et comme les
impôts puisque le siège départemental
partagent les lieux avec les impôts
étaient fermés on a bénéficié de la cour
aussi pour organiser des répartitions
denrées alimentaires avec des bénévoles
c'est en plein air pour limiter les
risques et ont donc du coup comme
beaucoup ont dit il a fallu réinventer
mais nous on aime bien ça en fait on a
même conceptualisé ça au secours
populaire on appelle ça réinventait la
solidarité c'est à dire que tout peut se
décliner sous l'angle de la solidarité
et là effectivement il a fallu faire
preuve d'un peu d'audace d'imagination
au sipi de souplesse d'organisation je
pense que c'est ça aussi la force de la
vie associative par rapport peut-être
des institutions qu'on des process plus
compliqué plus administratif et tous
nous au niveau des associations on a
quand même la chance je pense d'avoir un
petit peu plus de souplesse
d'organisation et quand on est une
association de solidarité comme nous sur
le terrain depuis 1945 et tout ça il ya
quand même un petit peu des réflexes et
ça fait aussi que
je sais pas pour balancer des fleurs au
secours populaire mais on a quand on est
quand même reconnu pour ça pour
l'adaptation des équipes et c'est vrai
que la souplesse fait par exemple qu on
a pu intervenir sur un hôtel social qui
avait pas été bien identifiés par les
autorités du département puisque c'était
du public qui n'aide paris on a pu se
projeter
on va dire plus rapidement que les uns
les instances administratives officielle
parce que c'est plus souple
donc on peut arriver avec un camion les
aides et des dépannages et puis ça a
créé beaucoup de cohésion et de
solidarité entre les gens croient que ce
soit des personnes qui sont qui sont
aidés aussi bien que les bénévoles en
fait une espèce d'union dans l'épreuve
quoi ça aurait inventé justement franck
les carpentier il fallait pallier cette
absence de saison il ya un challenge qui
a été créé oui effectivement en
collaboration avec l'île de france la
plupart des clubs franciliens se sont
réunis avec le club de rouen qui est
assez proche de chez nous et en fait on
a essayé d'organiser une compétition
avec les effectifs qu'on pouvait avoir
de manière à occuper les joueurs donc là
on a pu reprendre tout début septembre
par rapport à d'habitude ça ne m'attire
beaucoup plus loin puisque en fait on
signera tout début novembre
on espère juste un peu de clémence au
niveau de la météo mais du coup on a pu
s'occuper
alors les 3 septembre dernier le
gouvernement présenté un plan de relance
un plan de 100 milliards d'euros pour
favoriser notamment l'emploi des jeunes
il y aurait un appui de 190 millions qui
sera destiné aux missions locales à
l'accompagnement des jeunes en service
civique mais aussi aux associations
sportives
est ce que c'est une aide qui pourrait
vous intéresser ou pour nous est
vraiment dans l'aspect sportif d'alors
nous ça nous intéresse que effectivement
je n'ai pas cité tout à l'heure il y
avait un impact indirect qui n'était pas
lié au club
en fait le comité départemental essaye
de monter un emploi donc du coup on va
pleinement profiter de ces aides
puisqu'en fait on n'avait pas pu
recruter la personne en question et du
coup là on va là recrutés à partir du
mois d'octobre
du coup montini prend une bonne part des
heures de cet emploi donc du coup voilà
il y à 100 millions qui seront mis pour
les associations de prévention et de
lutte contre la pauvreté pour qu'elle
puisse déployer des actions spécifiques
exceptionnel pascal rodier est ce que
vous vous aussi vous pourriez en
bénéficier oui on travaille le dossier
on va dire ça se fait en coordination
avec les services de l'état un niveau
départemental et là c'est vrai aussi
qu'on a pu compter sur des
interlocuteurs quand même réactif et
vraiment disponibles en fait donc ça
c'est c'est à souligner aussi c'est que
une grosse attention une grosse
disponibilité du personnel de l'état et
donc c'est vrai que ça facilite et là on
est en train de travailler justement un
des volets qui devrait permettre de
combler aussi l'impossibilité que nous
avons eu quand même de faire des
initiatives de collecte financière telle
qu'on est habitué à les faire c'est à
dire que nous au niveau de l'association
on fonctionne aussi avec des vestiaires
solidaire avec des initiatives prises
par des bénévoles pour collecter les
fonds tout ça n'a pas pu être fait des
campagnes de solidarité comme la journée
des oubliés des vacances
nîmes sur la plage ça n'a pas pu se
faire il a fallu réinventer
[Musique]
on l'a déjà cet été avec le dispositif
vacances apprenantes on a quand même pu
faire partir de 160 enfants en colonie
de vacances
donc ça permet de faire un très beau
bilan de solidarité et sur les dès le
dernier quadrimestre je sais pas si ça
se dit mais sur les quatre dates quatre
derniers mois de l'année
on va voir bientôt il n'en restera plus
que trois on va démultiplier les efforts
et puis on peut reconstituer les stocks
alimentaires mine de rien puisque c'est
un peu vide 1 déjà on a un
approvisionnement par l'union européenne
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais ça prend un petit peu plus un peu
de retard par rapport aux autres années
donc on a un ou deux mois de décalage ce
qui fait qu'on a dotation 2020 qui va
arriver fin octobre voilà donc qui va
nous falloir acheter aussi des produits
alimentaires malheureusement parce qu'on
pourra pas tout collectés donc du coup
c'est vrai que il va falloir aussi
peut-être se rééquiper ou s'équiper
mieux pour faire face aux nouveaux
besoins donc notamment si on met en
place des rames as alimentaire dans les
magasins de produits frais il faut
s'équiper au frigo en congélateur adapté
en véhicule permettant de respecter la
chaîne du froid
tout ça c'est beau en terme de
solidarité mais ça coûte un peu des sous
et donc c'est vrai que le soutien de
l'état
je pense est nécessaire je pense qu'ils
ont compris qu'il était indispensable
aussi si vous voulez pas avoir d'effet
multiplicateur à la crise parce que là
c'est vrai qu' on n'est qu'au début des
effets pour les les intermittents les
artisans et les auto entrepreneurs les
étudiants puisque quand les activités
qui peut restauration bar et tout ça se
réduisent et bien les jobs permettant de
financer ses études
ça veut lui aussi il ya énormément de
problématiques qui sont pas encore tout
à fait réglé compris je pense des
professions libérales
des infirmiers mais aussi des
professions libérales quoi des avocats
des choses comme ça qui commence à avoir
les effets de cette crise réellement
arrivé c'est à dire qu'il ya il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de secteurs
professionnels qui vont être touchés et
ça fait que nous en tant qu'association
solidarité nous sommes plutôt habitués à
avoir des personnes en situation pré
karité économique
on va dire un peu structurelles pour
schématiser un peu et là on a vraiment
des nouveaux publics c'est à dire des
gens qui pensaient pas être avoir à
pousser la porte d'une association comme
le secours populaire pour manger ça
c'est vrai que c'est
c'est choquant un peu pour tout le monde
et ça nécessite des moyens qui
permettent de respecter la dignité
thoune c'est là qu'il faut que ça se
fasse aussi dans un air de manière digne
donc ça veut dire être en capacité
d'avoir beaucoup de bénévoles pour
ouvrir plus pour pouvoir accueillir les
personnes sans avoir dé des files
d'attentes de qui transpire la misère on
a envie de dire donc tout ça c'est un
travail en profondeur et des souvent
méconnus du grand public et qui est
interroge beaucoup les associations
comme la nôtre parce que ça veut dire
beaucoup de moyens derrière en fait donc
on a parfois un peu de scrupules à dire
que la solidarité c'est de l'argent mais
je pense qu'en fait il faut quand même
vraiment il insisté c'est que la
solidarité le geste de la sortie du
magasin quand vous faites vos courses de
t d une association qui fait de l'aide
alimentaire c'est bien mais derrière une
boîte de conserve a en fait il ya tout
un impact financier et humain qu'il faut
pouvoir accompagner ça c'est un vrai
enjeu en fait et vous françoise des
salles de l'air est-ce que
il y a dans le plan de relance des
indications qui pourrait vous aider à
maintenir le festival si jamais la crise
venait à a continué alors nos le
problème c'est aussi un festival les
conditions sanitaires sont quand même
primordial c'est à dire que si on ne
peut pas rassembler les personnes d'un
festival ne pas vivre
donc il ya déjà cet aspect là qui a fait
qu'on a eu depuis de reporter
l'événement prévu dimanche dernier
et puis il ya d'autres d'autres effet
c'est à dire que l'association anima
sauce elles existent aussi par la
création de l'espace culturel gratuit
qu'on avait qu'on avait créé dans
l'espace le centre commercial qui a été
fermée aussi au moment du confinement
tout ça tout ça c'est assez compliqué
alors c'est moins vital que ce qui
expliquait me suis relié
mais c'est vrai que la culture on le
sait bien c'est quand même aussi la
vitalité du vivre ensemble et ça fait
que ce ne sont pas que des mots que deux
voilà donc c'est vrai nom c'est
compliqué pour nous c'est très compliqué
parce que le plan de relance y touche
pas à les associations culturelles faut
quelqu'un qu'on tient on va conclure
avec vous certains de vos joueurs jouent
donc à l'étranger les autres et fille
sont bloqués ne joue pas ce que vous
avez peur de perdre vos effectifs
si ça venait à continuer et que les
matchs ne continue plus lu en france
alors déjà j'espère que ça arrivera pas
où se cache pas que vu qu'on parle d'
avril 2021
je pense que si ça continue on n'est pas
bien non après on a une vraie peur de ce
côté là dans le sens où on a des gens
qui sont champion de suède vice-champion
en suisse qu'ont joué des saisons sud
américaines qui ont un niveau nettement
supérieur au nôtre
donc oui effectivement
on a la peur de pas pouvoir maintenir
l'effectif non je vous cache pas qu'au
par rapport à la peur d'avoir à faire
mais le club c'était très secondaire
c'est un club 4,30 ont depuis peu et
voilà on essaye maintenant les objectifs
quand même pour 2021 sont assez
ambitieux puisqu'on envisage de au moins
les deux premières places pour fois
retourné en championnat d'europe
donc c'est quand même un challenge qui
motive les joueurs faut savoir que ce
qui est mis en avant chez nous il ya
très peu de turn over un effectif c'est
des gens qui sont là depuis plusieurs
années qu'ils aiment bien l'esprit
famille à montigny et dont je pense
qu'ils auront plaisir à redire et donc
c'est sur ces mots que nous allons
conclure cette émission merci à tous les
trois d'avoir accepté notre invitation
franck le quartier le challenge continue
les cougars joue contre euro en ce
dimanche 4 octobre
françoise de salles dès lors si tout va
bien le festival pulsations devrait se
tenir à les 25 et 26 septembre 2021 et
pascal roudier le 17 octobre prochain
c'est la journée mondiale du refus de la
misère c'est l'occasion notamment de
rappeler l'importance de toutes vos
actions le 7 une société revient lui à
la semaine prochaine nation
[Musique]